c'est une solution locale à la pollution
et à la congestion de bangalore des
vélos électriques indien en libre
service
c'est facile à utiliser ce nouvel usage
et ils aiment voir sur l'application
mobile le nombre de kilomètres reste un
avant la charge
youlou est arrivé sur le marché il y a
trois ans en adaptant pour le marché
indien la technologie des trottinettes
électriques dans cette entreprise
émergente on tenait à éviter le piège
des années 90 en inde
c'est à dire de travailler pour une
compagnie étrangère qui offre un service
ou même une technologie développée
ailleurs matt barnes mitchell
les gens ici aiment essayer de nouveaux
produits dit le cofondateur de youlou
c'est un énorme avantage pour les
entreprises de bangalore amit gupta
oeuvre dans les hautes technologies
depuis 20 ans il a vu la transformation
du secteur une génération
d'informaticiens indien lance maintenant
leur propre jeune société après avoir
fait leurs classes dans les bureaux
locaux d'entreprises américaines comme
google et microsoft n va et because mes
potes au mastic manqué lui par la taille
du marché indien est un immense avantage
pour la réussite des entrepreneurs d'ici
croit-il dès le lancement il faut penser
à servir des centaines de millions
d'usagers étaient sortis avec son
immense bassin de talents locaux bon
marché sa capacité d'attraction
d'entreprises et de capitaux étrangers
bangalore et l'écosystème technologique
qui a connu la croissance la plus rapide
depuis 2016 devant des villes comme
londres paris et munich de bengalore
cette femme enseigne le théâtre en ligne
à des enfants du canada du japon et de
l'inde
la jeune entreprise bambino est une
plateforme web d'activités parascolaires
elle a été lancée en pleine pandémie
après avoir travaillé pour amazon en
inde haschich gupta a décidé d'utiliser
le savoir faire qu'il a acquis pour
fonder sa propre entreprise
il considère les nombreux centres de
recherche accélérateur d'entreprises
émergentes et espaces de travail commun
de bangalore comme des facteurs
importants de réussite elle
ça nous permet de contrôler nos coûts et
d'ajouter de l'espace de bureau ou
besoin dit il la pandémie n'a pas
affecté les perspectives de croissance à
bangalore les grues et chantiers de
construction font partie du paysage
la caisse de dépôt et placement du
québec investit un demi milliard de
dollars dans la construction d'édifices
commerciaux dans le sud de l'inde l'un
des premiers projets une tour de bureaux
à bangalore et même taxe obésité
écosystèmes c'est normal d'attirer
autant d'investissements croit-il l'inde
a pris le virage du paiement mobile
depuis trois ans ce qui représente des
centaines de millions de consommateurs
potentiels de plus partout en inde
plus que jamais la promesse de
l'eldorado indien semble réel et c'est
philippe leblanc radio canada magalas